a little over 100 years ago in 1915
ainstein published his theory of
general relativity that he is a
strange middle man but this is a theory that
explains gravity it
says that the masses of all the
planets attract each other
not because they are attracted by an
instantaneous force  as newton said but
because all the matter
all of us all the planets
wrinkle the flexible fabric of space
time and the space time I have made
in which we live and connects us all like
when we lie down on a
mattress and more so the mattress and the
masses move not again not because
of newton's laws but because they see in that
curvature of space time they were
following the curves just like when
our bedfellow came closer to us
due to the curvature of the cork
a year later in 1916 to extend fig
that his theory of his theory that
gravitational waves existed,
that they were produced when masses
move, for example when two
stars are rotating a  around each
other and produce space-
time folds that take energy from the system
and the stars get closer
, however he also said he calculated that
these effects were so so so small
that they were never going to be able to be measured I'm going
to tell you how with him  work of hundreds
of scientists working from many
countries for many decades very
little time ago in 2015 we
discovered those gravitational waves
by the actress for the first time this is
quite a long story it
started me
300 million years
ago a long long time ago in a galaxy
very  very far
there were two black holes they were
spinning around each other
dancing a tango I like to say that it
started slow but as they emitted
gravitational waves they got
closer and accelerated until here
when they were spinning at almost the
speed of light they merged into one
only a woman or a black man who had 60 times the
mass of the sun but was compact in 360
kilometers,
that's for him  size of the state of
louisiana where i live this
incredible effect produced gravitational waves
that carried and message of this hug
with mica to the rest of the universe it took us a
long time to discover the effect of
these gravitational waves because what
they do the way doctors
are looking for  e effects on distances
we want to measure lengths
distances when these
gravitational waves passed through the earth
that passed in 2015 produced
changes of the changes in all the
distances between the distances between
you the distances between you and
it our heights we all
reach out and stretch  we shrink a little
the prediction is that the effect is
proportional to the distance but it is
tiny even for distances
much greater than my low height
the effect is infinitesimal
for example the distance between the earth
and the sun
changed by an atomic diameter
how can it be measured  that how we could
measure that about 50 years ago there was a
visionary physicists in ghent kim haiti
jackson have not provided rei baix who
thought that distance could be
precisely measured using the ce is
that they gave me distances between mirrors and
here they were miles
away from me it
took many many years and a lot of work
and many scientists to develop  the
technology developed the ideas and 20
years later almost 30 years ago more than
20 began to build two
gravitational wave detectors 2
interferometers in the united states
each four kilometers long
and one in the state of louisiana in
levingston viciana in the middle  from a
beautiful forest the other in hanford washington
the state of vocento in the middle of the
desert in these interferometers
we have the women who travel from the
center four kilometers in a vacuum they are
reflected in mirrors and return and we are
measuring the difference in distance
between this arm and this  arm and these
detectors are very very very sensitive they are
the most precise instruments  s of the world
because we made two because the signals
that we want to measure well in space
are the ones that we want to measure but the
mirrors are moving all the time
so to distinguish gravitational wave effects
that are
astrophysical effects and must appear in the two
detectors we can distinguish the and  the
local effects that appear different
in one another
in September 2015 we were
finishing installing the second
generation of technology in these
detectors and we were still not
at the optimum sensitivity
that we want we are still not there
even two years later but already
we wanted to take data
we don't think we are going to see anything but
we are preparing to start taking
data for a few months and nature
surprised us on September 14,
we saw a gravitational wave in both detectors
we saw a signal with a few cycles in both detectors  that
grew in amplitude and frequency and
after street and were the  themselves in
the two detectors were gravitational waves
and not only that but by encoding
this waveform
we could deduce that they came from
black holes merging into one
more than a billion years ago
this was more
this was fantastic
at first we couldn't believe it  this is
not supposed to happen tomás avetta if it
was a surprise to all of us it took us
months to convince ourselves that this was
true because we did not want to give rise to
any error but it was true and to
remove any doubt that the
detectors could actually measure these things in
december  of the same year
we measured another gravitational wave small
sea that the first the first
habitation wave produced a difference in
distance of four thousandths soon
news about 4,000 men and the second
detection was smaller but still very
convincing by our
standards despite the fact that these are
space time waves not sound waves
we like to put them in
speakers and listen  harlas
we say to this the music of the universe
here I want to make you listen to the
first two notes of this music
[Music]
the second the shortest was the last
fraction of a second of these two
black holes that in that fraction of
that world emitted a lot  of energy as
much energy as that of three suns
becoming energy
following that famous formula the same
months saved do you remember this
music actually we love it so much we
dance with this that I am going to hear
gunshots
[Music]
the music of the universe
frequently people ask me
now what are gravitational waves for
and now that they have only discovered what remains
to be done here are gravitational waves
when borges
asked him what poetry is for in
in turn he asked what the
decisive dawn is for in caresses
what is the smell for  to coffee and the pse
answered poetry is for pleasure
for emotion to live and understand the
universe  this human curiosity to
know how everything works is similar
to humanity since time immemorial and
all of us all of you as children
when you look at the sky for the first time
and see stars you wonder what
stars are
that curiosity is what makes us
human  and that's what we do with
science we like to say gravitational waves
are already working
because we're opening up a new way
to explore the universe so far
we can see starlight
through electromagnetic waves
now we can hear the  sound of the
universe even from things that do not emit light
with gravitational waves
[Applause]
only paradise will work or it will not
happen no technology is derived from
gravitational waves maybe yes but it will probably
take a long time we have developed
technology to detect the but the
waves  themselves, perhaps 100 years from now they will be discovered
that they are useful for something but it
takes a long time to derive  chnology
of science and that's not why we
do it all technology is derived from
science but science we do it
for pleasure we have a
lot a lot left to do this is just the
beginning as we make the
detectors more sensitive and we have a
lot left  to do not only are we going to see
more black holes we are going to be able to make
a catalog to know how many there are where they
are juan grande son but we are also
going to see other objects
we are going to see the merger of
neutron stars that become a
black hole let's go  we are going to see a
black hole being born
we are going to be able to see rotating stars in
our galaxy producing
sinusoidal waves we are going to be able to see
supernova explosions in our
galaxy it is a whole spectrum of new
sources that we are going to be seeing we
like to say that we have added a new
sense to the human body now in addition to
seeing we can hear this is a
revolution in astronomy just like
when galiño invented the tele  I copy or
like when sound was added to silent movies
this is just the beginning we like to
think that the path of science is
very long very funny but very long and
this great international community of
scientists working as a team from
many countries all together we are
helping to build this path by
laying the is sometimes finding
detours
and perhaps building a highway
the universe behind the
[Music]